bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
bonsoir doster nos grands maîtres et
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
les résultats sont donc bon sur le plan
sanitaire sanitaire nous dit edouard
philippe
à partir du 2 juin la liberté va devenir
à la règle et l'interdiction deviendra
l'exception le médecin que vous êtes
comment il juge cette nouvelle stratégie
du gouvernement
non mais simplement on voit bien dans
coke évier depuis maintenant une petite
semaine que les tests que l'on réalise
reviennent plutôt négatif que la
contamination entre des personnes est de
moins en moins importante et on se rend
bien compte que la virulence du virus a
nettement diminué malheureusement je
pense que beaucoup de politiques vont
vouloir crier victoire mais je ne suis
pas certain que chevalier réellement à
une stratégie politique mais simplement
l'effet naturel du train de décliner
alors ça veut dire concrètement dr
legrand que didier rahout dont on a
beaucoup parlé cette semaine avait
finalement un petit peu raison quand
même sur ce coup là il avait dit
effectivement cette épidémie selon lui
s'évaporer avec la saison estivale elle
deviendrait comme elle est apparue
est ce que vous le rejoignez dans cette
analyse aujourd'hui sur ce point il
avait décidé de lui dédier sa et il a
dit exactement l'inversé aussi des
choses donc en gros fissures log
il y a pas de problème il a fui bon
après faut entrer plaisanterie
effectivement d'épidémie ça se termine
généralement nationalement
heureusement il faut quand même se
rappeler que à chaque fois l'état a
beaucoup de retard pour se mettre en
place pour diminuer les mandats et la
décontamination et on va avoir la chance
d'avoir un milliard de masques qui
devrait arriver fin du mois de juin
donc s'ils ont des stocks qui compte
vraiment pas normalement que la
prochaine étape
alors docteur de grands rouleaux dit
c'est pas vraiment dû à la stratégie du
gouvernement
ça veut dire que le confinement n'y est
pour rien où il aurait quand même
évidemment fait peut-être plus de deux
victimes
mais il a joué quand même dans ce frein
comme la tête et dénis aujourd'hui le
confinement a été essentielle le
confinement c'est la sanction quand on
n'avait pas ce qu'il fallait c'est à
dire que parce que l'on n'avait pas
masquer parce que on n'a pas mis en
place de zones de fins de tests
aléatoires
il nous a fallu mettre en place le
confinement et tous les pays qui ont
réussi à faire sortir entre guillemets
ont mis en place un test massif du
masquage systématique
clairement si on n'a pas encore compris
ça il lui faudra encore attendre de les
vider les puces
bon voilà mais il faudrait désespérer ou
de 50 ou 60 ans on devrait commencer à
comprendre qu'il fera des stocks de
masques et qu'il faut les mettre en
distribution libre et que l'on doit voir
du gel hydroalcoolique dans les lieux de
rassemblement
mais j'ai pas encore vu de mesures qui
demande au lieu de rassemblement de le
faire donc a priori je pense que pour la
prochaine fois on va pouvoir recommencer
le même site
alors justement les lieux de
rassemblement en même temps ils sont
interdits pour le moment en tout cas au
delà de 10 personnes vous trouvez que
c'est encore sévère ou le danger
justement viendrait précisément de la de
rassemblement voilà rassemblés au
rassemblement avec beaucoup de personnes
évidemment il faut effectivement se
rappeler quand même que l'épidémie
partie d'une personne à l'origine d'un
casier au même s'il était vu plusieurs
casinos en france
au démarrage mais fait était unique
yannick s'est répandue très vite happé
qu'effectivement on peut avoir des
résurgences ça se voit ça s'est déjà vu
c'est pas le cas le plus fréquent
didiéni mais ça peut arriver et donc du
coup il faut rester effectivement
vigilant et on sait qu'aujourd'hui il
n'ya pas des personnes qui sont des
supers contaminateur non à des lieux qui
sont des super content et le net
et dès que vous êtes en situation
confine et on compense tout à fait un
commissariat on va penser aux transports
en commun
on va penser une voiture un train il est
évident que se propagent à une très
grande rapidité et on a ou le crs a
encore envoyé un mail quelques quelques
heures des hommes de kloster qui sont
honnêtement identifiés et d'ailleurs qui
ont été identifiés et je m'en réjouis
grâce à des tests aléatoires dont deux
pour le nord pas de calais que j'ai été
dans mon propos kevin et donc voilà on
revient toujours à la même à la même
stratégie il faut tester tester tester
et ils veulent et personne positive
justement j'allais y venir catherine et
nous le disent et l'épidémiologiste
qu'on a eu en invité il ya quelques
minutes me disais voilà il faut tester
c'est la solution peut-être plutôt que
d'interdire les rassemblements de tester
à l'entrée de ces rassemblements que ce
soit des rassemblements privé public des
trains c'est selon vous une situation
viable pour éviter justement une
éventuelle propagation
alors maintenant quand on arrive en fin
de vie des mines
par définition le nombre de tests
positifs j'ai très faibles donc il va
falloir faire plus at il une 2000 tests
pour réussir à avoir un seul cas positif
et donc il va falloir beaucoup de
persévérance c'était le moment où il
faut être
accroche s'accrocher et des amendes
pointilleux pour continuer à tester
alors qu'on a l'impression de ne plus
avoir aucun bénéfice de ce test est fait
je rappelle que des trains tests
aléatoires et sûrement pas un test sont
symptomatiques puisqu'il faut l'isoler
immédiatement et fantomatique on sait
que aujourd'hui la majeure partie de la
contamination se fait dans la phase non
épidémique
et je rappelle puisque je vois l'image
votre reportage qu'il ne faut pas mettre
le masque soul man comme on boit
toujours effectivement donc les tests
effectivement l'application stop
qu'ovide edouard philippe s'est arrêté
quelques instants vantant les mérites de
cette application qui d'ailleurs a été
approuvé par les députés de l'assemblée
nationale cette semaine votre réaction
l'application stop que vite c'est
absolument fabuleux c'est exactement ce
qu'il nous fallait les ya six mois donc
c'est bien on pourra s'en servir pour la
prochaine fois
j'ai eu tant que les gouvernements à se
mettre en place on arrive à avoir toutes
les bonnes mesures mais à la fin qui
donne vraiment l'impression d'avoir tout
fait que luc ferry
on a juste oublié qu'on l'ait d'avion
avait lancé que c'est pas grave
sachez enfin comme d'habitude mieux vaut
tard que jamais voilà tenter de conclure
si tenté qu'il se faire dans ce genre de
sujet dramatique par une boutade un
petit peu plus légères merci à vous en
tout cas bertrand legrand d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france